欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课。
同学们,第11小节我们来讲最后一种组合爆款标题的方法。怎么样把潜力产品的标题优化成为爆款的标题。潜力产品通常来说它是有一定的数据,而且是款式也是挺好的。但是呢,这个产品的流量就是相对来说比较少的。
前提就是这类潜力产品标题覆盖的关键词数量少,因为它的词少导致它缺流量,曝光点击少。但是它的转化很好,或者是它的词的流量指数太小了。所以说推广也是很难获得流量的情况下,我们要采取的方法就是把这个产品的标题进行一个优化。接下来我们来看一下具体的一个优化的流程。
第一个就是选对产品,你要把这个类的潜力品的按照这个标准去选择。选到了之后,然后我们在产品分析360里面去看,这个关键词分析,它的曝光点击的词都有哪些。你要看的时间一定是按周,以及按月的数据,不断的往前推延去看数据的。
把这些词什么,有
寻盘的,有TM的,有店内订单的关键词,不要改动,留下有效的词,这些词是有效的词,留下有效词,同时有点击量的词,精准的词,也要把这些词留下来。比如说这是标题,里面有A,B,C,D,E,F,G,长串的关键词组合成的这个标题。
这里面肯定是A,B,C,D,E,F,G,里面肯定是有有效词,肯定也有一些是无效的词的。那么我们有效词怎么判断,DM,有询盘,有订单,有点击,甚至有一些曝光量比较好的精准词,这就是有效词,把这些里面的有效词留下来。我们去找到无效词,我们找的时候一定三个月或者三个周多维度的去找。
如果维度的去找,不要只看一周也不要只看一个月,比如说月你就按照三个月的数据去看,周的话你就按照一两三周以上的数据去看,然后我们就开始去找无效的词。那么无效的词就是没有刚才我们讲的这些指标数据的词,你在标题这里面去把,比如说刚才我们讲A,B,C,D,E,F,U,比如说我们找到里面的词,C这个关键词,
这个关键词还有F这个关键词,它基本没有流量,而且是搜索指数非常低的,甚至是零的,没有原收的,那么这种词你就去找一些新的词去替换跟增补。去找什么样的词去替换跟增补呢?首先第一个就是要有搜索指数的,第二个就是要有点击量的,点击率的词,第三个就是这类词最近是上涨的,就是它的搜索指数
都是上涨的这些词,第四个就是必须是精准的产品词,第五个就是与产品非常匹配的,这个款式非常匹配的这些词去加,知道了符合这五个条件,如果你还是没有听清楚,那么你可以暂停或者是回放再听一下这五个标准,让它五个标准去选这些替捕跟替换跟增补的词,如果是你无效词你也听不清楚,那么你就按照前面去看,把这几个
指标明确的去选去替换,替换了之后呢,一定要马上推广,因为我们之前讲过,改标题是会影响到整体产品的数据的,所以说你快速的推广,让这个产品的权重维持,产品的权重维持,那么它原始保留的那些有效的词,才能够稳定住它的排名,才能够让你整个产品不至于流量下跌,还会持续的增长,这是一个非常重要的一环,
我们一定要马上去往,那么最后面,我们来注意几个非常关键的点,第一个优质产品,不要轻易改变标题,就是我们的这些潜力产品,按照这些几个维度去选,而不要选那些爆品,本来如果是爆品,本来效果非常好的,你非要去改动标题,那么你就会导致,可能流量就下降了,一定要慎重去修改,第二个就是原始标题的关键,顺序尽量往直一字,比如说刚才我们讲的ABCDEFGA,
ABCDEFGA这种顺序原始的,比如说他AB是一个主额词,那么他原始的顺序就是AB,如果你把它调整了,调整成BA这个词,变成这个词组的话,那么他的效果就可能就没有这个AB,原始的顺序效果好了,所以说一定要注意他原始的顺序在关键词指数是什么样的顺序,就是使用什么样的顺序,第三个就是如果这个产品效果本身不错,又非要改标题,
那么最好的做法就是改完了之后,马上去推广,这样的产品的流量才能够稳定,且还有增长的机会。好了,上面就是关于我们怎么样去把一个潜力产品改成报款标题的一个方法,这个方法也适用于我们平时的一些产品的优化,也是非常适用的,无论哪个行业都可以用这个方法,现在就可以马上行动起来了。好了,这节课我们就先讲到这里,下节课
慢慢再来